[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to the group
chat live in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel i'm natalie bodie
filling in for the man the myth the
legend greg ivory today
but don't worry we still have the real
star of the show here and that is liv
moods liv i am so excited to be on here
with you how are you doing today
they're um you know of course we miss
greg but you're incredible so i'm
excited to talk something i know finally
getting to do a show together you guys
got both of us today
by the way i don't even have a pair of
so those are exclusive you guys are
gonna get those today but i need you to
get in the comments
we need an emoji of course as greg would
say winners only please and in fact
we're actually gonna give out some of
those shorts i was talking about
right now so let me get in the comments
see what you guys are saying
we got dave iron viking in here he's
putting a bunch of gifts dave you're
gonna get a pair just for that i love
the good vibes but liv i might be new to
the show but i know how you guys roll
around here and it's game day so we are
betting the three by two
the question is will there be two three
pointers made in the first three minutes
of the game
we asked you guys on twitter which 3x2
will cash tonight
celtics versus bucks or grizzlies versus
a warrior so let's take a look at those
results from the twitter bowl
liv what are you thinking here
yeah i mean normally i fade the public
i'm a big public fader but i think the
public is is definitely correct in this
we have seen the memphis grizzlies
struggle in the postseason with their
perimeter defense we saw in the last
season or series versus the timberwolves
and we're seeing it in this series again
versus the golden state warriors i mean
you've got the splash triplets jordan
pool clay thompson steph curry against a
struggling perimeter defense i don't
think it'll end well um i mean it will
end well for us with the 3x2 so i am
liking the 3x2 in that matchup not to
mention the warriors ranked top five in
both three-pointers made and attempted
in the postseason so i think the public
is right on this one and i think the
three by two we should ride tonight is
the warriors versus the grizzlies
i love it liv and i need you guys to get
back in the comments i'm gonna come back
see what you guys think but i do want to
shout out my guy dave because i didn't
read his at and it's at iron viking dave
you're bringing all the good vibes i
mentioned him earlier let's see what you
guys think of the three by two
all right we got kevin at cayman kelly
submitting a chat in here you're gonna
get some merch kevin
but the decision is made we are riding
the warriors versus the grizzlies that's
the three by two that we are rocking
with
now let's talk some major markets
moneyline spread and point totals for
tonight's games let's go ahead and take
a look at tonight's odds
liv what are you thinking here
we're gonna bring that one up all right
tell me what sticks out to you liv what
you got
yeah i'm actually liking both the home
teams tonight to cover the spread i know
that that grizzlies game has now moved
that that line has moved and it's now
plus four for the grizzlies but let's
not forget this grizzlies team was 20
and five without john morant we don't
have john marant tonight i think we see
a big game from tyus jones we saw steven
adams with his first start since april
19th with a dominant game he had a
double double he was doing great on both
sides of the ball so i'm really liking
the grizzlies to cover at home and the
celtics i'm also liking them to cover
the spread at home we're seeing the
momentum being kind of shifted in this
series i think a lot of people were a
little nervous at first for the celtics
team but there is no denying the celtics
offense and defense we're seeing guys
like al horford i am a big al horford
stand right now really loving the way
he's playing ball their defense is
electric and like i said i think they're
gaining momentum at the right time
they're taking it back at home so i'm
gonna wrap with both the home teams
tonight to cover
liv i like it and we know how it went
with home teams last night i was on the
wrong side of both of those and they
were both blow out so i like it a lot
but we're gonna get back in those
comments see what the people have to say
let's go ahead and see what you guys
think
drop some comments let us know what you
think is a lot tonight
all right i'm gonna read this one right
here i'm going off the screen we've got
dread flock couple extra o's and c's in
there we're gonna get your username down
though and get you some merch bucks
moneyline and warriors moneyline all
right shout out to you you are going
home with some merch today
but we talked those major markets and
now we're gonna get into player props
liv i know this is one of your
specialties so once again you guys get
in the comments tell me if you think
these props are locks or not because
that's exactly what it's time for lock
or not and we are going to start with
steph
curry so will steph curry score over 27
points tonight that is the question it's
at minus 120 liv what do you think
steph's gonna do tonight 27 plus
yeah i mean i saw a couple quotes from
him today that he basically said we're
gonna we're gonna tidy up this series
tonight i still have faith in the
grizzlies to cover the spread but steph
is talking like they are trying to end
it tonight they want to win this thing
out so
let you know steph curry in the regular
season he was averaging 36.3 points
against this grizzlies team he's only
not hit this over once in this series
but again this is steph curry we're
talking about arguably the most
consistent offensive player on this team
uh we've been seeing him do what he does
best especially down the stretch in that
fourth quarter when they need him to be
clutch he has figured it out i think he
does the same thing tonight so because
he's trying to clean up this series and
he has pretty much made that very very
clear i like him to score 27 plus and
try to get the job done but i am still
hoping the grizzlies cover
all right we are going to go back to
those comments and tap in with our
audience to see what they think can
steph do it tonight
sheldon434 says warriors close out shout
out to you sheldon you will be getting
some merch then we have richie 21 he
says steph's going under you'll also be
getting some merch keep the comments
rolling you guys we are gonna transition
to jaron jackson jr
will he have over six rebounds this one
is at minus 118. liv what do you think
here
i'm actually not loving this prop
tonight and i'm a huge jaron jackson
junior fan i have been all season i've
loved the way he's played defensively
throughout the entire regular season but
we have stephen adams coming back like i
said in his last game against the
warriors uh steven adams had a
double-double he had 15 rebounds six of
which were offensive and i think that
has actually been the grizzlies weakness
in this series is rebounding uh jaron
jackson jr had only five rebounds last
game and three the game before that and
with steven adams coming back i think he
has less opportunities at getting those
boards so i don't love this play tonight
i'm gonna say it's not a lock
all right you heard it not a lock from
live moods let's see what the comments
think we have
nbbl noah he says over all right good
vibes right there from noah you'll be
getting some merch
see what else we think in here mrx2 kept
it simple just put the lock emoji we
love to see the lock emoji we're going
to move on lastly though we have
draymond green
to have over
six assists that one's a little bit
higher price at minus 142. liv what you
got for me with draymond
yeah like i said steven adams coming
back in this game i think that's gonna
put a little bit of pressure on draymond
that he hasn't really felt with this
grizzlies team yet um i think he did
last game we saw steven adams just
playing very very dominant and
aggressive basketball which was super
exciting to watch but i think that
that's gonna put a little bit of
pressure on draymond offensively so i do
like him facilitating a little bit more
in this match up i think the bet hits i
think it's a lock but would i personally
take it at -142
no i would not the value is not there um
so i think it's a great bet i just
wouldn't put my money on it
all right if you didn't know liv and i
both love a plus sign so we're not
always wanting to pay up but i want to
know what you guys think
tapping back in with you guys
all right so we have
wags 22 once again just keeping it
simple with lock you're gonna get some
merch and then c cunningham three says
under interesting so you guys are head
to head not as confident and that's kind
of how we were feeling too
but all right you guys
let's move on because it is time to
build the vr betting custom
same game parlay which you can ride with
us on fanduel tonight we're actually
looking at the celtics bucks game and i
need everyone once again to let us know
what you think because of course we're
going to tap in with our audience which
legs are locks and which legs are not
so let's go ahead and start building out
that four leg br betting same game
parlay
so for the first one here liv we're
gonna take a look at jason
tatum
tonight he needs to score 25 plus points
in our same game parlay can he do it
what do you think
i mean is he capable of doing it of
course he is he's only done this twice
in this series but i think the only
worrying factor for me with this bet
particularly is that jason tatum is
finally getting help i mean offensively
we saw al horford with a 30-plus game um
last game jaylen brown in my opinion is
playing a little bit more consistently
on offense which has been great to see
mark is smart maybe hit or miss so jason
tatum has some help and that's the only
thing that worries me about 25 plus but
like i said the celtics are trying to
get that momentum and keep that momentum
they're playing back at home so i have
faith that jason tatum can do it
because will we see another 30-plus game
from horford
we could but the consistency there is
you know maybe unlikely we may see him
do well but maybe not 30 plus so i think
jason tatum will have to score well
tonight to keep the celtics in this one
because i think the bucks are gonna
really try uh to put up a fight so i'm
gonna say it's a good bet we may sweat
it out just a little bit but he's
definitely capable of 25 plus
all right you heard it it's a sweat but
he's capable all right our next leg
giannis scoring 30 plus points liv talk
to me 30 plus is kind of a lot but it's
the honest we're talking about
right it is a lot um but fading giannis
never feels great you know it just kind
of feels like it's a sin or something
you just don't you never feel good about
doing it um i will say in the first two
games of this series when playing on the
road he was held to 24 and 28 points now
that's still a lot of points but for
giannis not really i mean he's such a
dominant force on offense for this bucks
team so because i'm on the celtics to
cover the spread i'm really liking the
celtics defense to lock up giannis a
little bit so 30 may be tough for him
but again it's giannis we're talking
about so fading him is never a great
idea so i definitely think it's a it's a
great part of the parlay it's a great
leg because it's giannis and it's the
playoffs so um
i think 30 plus is a high number but i
think he can get it done
giannis is a star and that's what we
need him to be tonight he's definitely
capable we're gonna go to our next leg
though drew holiday to record six plus
assists what do you think liv
yeah i'm liking this one again i think
that celtics defense is really gonna try
to lock up those guys offensively um and
keep the momentum in this series so i
think he's gonna be forced to facilitate
a little bit more in this game so i like
this leg this is probably the leg i feel
the most confident about
all right rounding out the same game
parlay jalen brown three plus made
threes liv how confident are you about
this one
you know three's plays are never my
favorite um those are probably the best
i sweat out the absolute most in the nba
but i will say like i mentioned earlier
we're seeing way more consistency from
jalen brown in this you know in the
postseason actually he's been playing
very well if you're nervous about this
one hopefully this will make you feel a
little bit better uh jaylen brown has
hit this twice in this series and the
two games that he hid it um they were in
boston playing at home and they are back
in boston playing at home so hopefully
he lights it up he has a lot of clutch
threes in this game uh because he does
come in very clutch with his threes
pretty consistently in these games so
three plus if you're stressing about it
let's just let's just hope that that
home court advantage will work in his
favor and he'll hit this one for us
all right let's go ahead and put that
ticket up we got plus 446 loving the
value there 100 bucks will make you
almost 450. but liv i know that you're
our parlay queen around here what are
you grading our parlay today
yeah so you're you're new to the show
for with me anyway and um
if i've graded a parlay a b minus it
typically does a whole lot better than
when i graded anything else so i'm going
to give it a b minus i'm going to keep
the good vibes rolling hopefully we keep
the good vibes rolling and we can cash
out on this parlay so b minus it is and
i'm going to stick with that hoping that
hoping that it gives us some good energy
all right d minus if you know you know
and i'm new so i got that briefing too
i'm feeling good about it the b minus
i'll rock with it let's see what you
guys think in the comments
we have jay gagne says tatum goes for 50
okay feeling confident wow then we have
christina l melton locked
and then chris k james says
high scoring night all will hit chris we
love those good vibes on this show all
of you guys are going to get shorts
we're giving away jerseys all the merch
but you guys keep the comments coming
we'd love to tap in and see what you
guys think
well greg is not here today so i've got
to step in and talk about his warriors
uh because you know that's that's what
he loves to talk about on this show uh
before we get started here are the
current series odds for this grizzlies
warriors series going into tonight's
game you can see the warriors are at
minus 4 000 yikes i don't think i would
ever put money on that and the grizzlies
are at plus
1500. uh what are your thoughts on this
so far
all right so even though i'm wearing my
celtics green tonight because i'm hot on
them liv i'm going to go ahead and say
would i bet this at minus 4 000 no but
do i think golden state closes it out
tonight i do and here's why
even last game when they were down by 10
i found myself saying i'm just waiting
for them to come back i know they're
gonna do it steph curry is steph curry
he has been more inefficient in steph
curry's standards from beyond the ark
this season but he's had the highest
percentage of two point shots finished
inside the arc he has a complete game i
can't bet against him the grizzlies
without jon marant i just can't bet on
them so i'm going with golden state
closing it out
fair enough and i can't argue again he's
kind of like giannis for me you can't
really fade him um and ever feel really
great about it i i am fading you however
i am rocking with the grizzlies tonight
and that might be a huge mistake i think
the grizzlies can get one more win in
this series uh without john moran the
regular season they were 20 and five i
think tyus jones is a little bit of a
sleeper i think he's a great uh you know
secondary behind john moran i think he
will do what he needs to do
hopefully we'll see a stronger game from
desmond bane i know he's been battling a
little bit of a back issue dylan brooks
i think will feel a little bit more
comfortable playing at home rather than
hearing boos from the crowd every time
he touched the ball stephen adams is
back he had a great game so i'm gonna
rock with the grizzlies tonight and hope
hope and pray that they can get at least
one more win so i don't think they're
gonna close out tonight but i definitely
think the warriors will take it back to
san francisco and close it out in the
next game so that's that's my prediction
but we'll see
all right guys liv and i are on opposite
sides of this one so we got to see what
you guys think
first thing i'm seeing iowa forever 90
says grizzlies in a tight one for me
okay so they are team live
we got iowa 190 on the grizzlies yup and
then goat garden says warriors easy lock
no chance without jaw
you guys are getting merged but
nothing's easy in the playoffs i'm with
you liv i'm a little bit nervous you
guys are going home with merch though
and we talked the warriors and the
grizzlies now let's talk about this
explosive celtics team
we've been seeing them just really light
it up in the playoffs i want to know if
you think liv can they go all the way
but first let's take a look at the
current nba finals odds
liv what are your thoughts here
yeah i think celtics is a great option
that plus 440 i mean this was a celtics
team that in the regular season had the
best defense in terms of points allowed
to their opponent right now in the
postseason they have the third best
defense in terms of points allowed to
their opponent like i said offensively
we're seeing great performances from
guys like al and marcus smart uh he's
hit or miss but he's here nor there uh
you've got jason tatum jaylen brown
they're just they're really stacked on
both sides of the ball so i'm really
liking the celtics but
defense wins championships which is why
i like the celtics but i feel like if
i'm going to talk about defense winning
championships i also have to mention the
miami heat because right now in the
postseason they are giving up the fewest
points to their opponent so they have
the best defense in the postseason right
now i'm loving watching them play i
think the series between them and the
76ers has definitely gotten interesting
since embiid came back but this miami
heat team is strong on both sides of the
ball just like the celtics team so i
know there's a lot of excitement around
the western conference with the warriors
and the suns but i think the eastern
conference is where you really gotta
watch out because like i said defense
wins championships and defense in the
eastern conference is definitely legit
right now
all right we're tapping back into those
comments you guys already know i've got
on my green for the celtics
snoopy 2153 though i'm a newer fan i'm
just gonna own up to it he says he's
been on the celtics since they were plus
4 900. snoopy 2153
you're getting some merch
then we have nbl noah says celtics are
stepping up yeah i agree with you they
definitely are you guys are going to get
merch one of you is going to get a
jersey
but thank you guys so much for tapping
in to the group chat presented by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the 3x2 is a lock the br betting same
game parlay is a lock we will be back
next wednesday greg once again will be
in this spot and liv will be with you
they're gonna be giving away more socks
jerseys and of course more locks so if
you want a prize today don't worry we
will be dming you but alongside live
moods i'm natalie bodie so much fun to
join you guys today and we are leaving
the group chat
[Music]
you